[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yes I'm great
the detectives really asked me this time
to not interfere with the murder
investigation
but what mama down now down harder but
don't worry
uncle PJ is here and he will be taking
care of you this is a good idea you can
have good ideas Lena at your own
restaurant doctor so what will they perk
on I need to dazzle which is why our new
menu is entirely exotic meats now be a
good sous chef and season the shark
fillets and what about my race let's see
how the seasoning goes hmm
hi mom yep I'll be home later I'll make
something good for dinner it's just
tight right now don't worry I won't quit
I love you too
can you grab my jacket please
coming right up I've gotta hand it to
you Phil you were a man of note you're
on fire today PJ it's on the table
a big bruise you hold dog you I bet he
was in this freaky hey they died of
natural causes you crazy people I have a
permit mr. bass
my name is Billy more water I think
you're a sick deranged man can't you see
these creatures deserve life I deserve
I'm sorry am I gonna get one no and just
so you know everything dies a tattoo
maybe from a secret society just another
basic [ __ ] I can't run a business with
protesters out on the patio so call the
cops it's not just that man look out our
reservations have been cut nearly in
half since we started selling this this
Tiger paws are deaf dishes are going to
save our Michelin star whoo nobody wants
to eat this weird stuff yeah well you
don't remember when I butchered that
turkey in front of you I've never seen
anyone pass out so quickly
Vlado family Margaret wants to go to
Cabo
and we need to be making profit and
right now we just need a good review
[Music]
Elaine tattoo didn't take you down
though was the old bottle to the head
usually not enough to kill but to well
for 500 points what is fatal stab wound
only question remains who could have
done such a thing was it Lena the
ambitious sous chef Billy the animal
rights activist or Jeff Phil struggling
business partner Phil We Need to Talk
this again listen when I'm gone you
could run the restaurant that sound good
I'm going home
[Music]
rest in peace Ville hey cook up a storm
for me in heaven will ya
[Music]
[Music]